So, let's look at the speed versus power
versus weight versus cost quiz answer. We were
asked, which one of these is the worst
laptop processor? The crawlium, slowium, laptium, fastium, hotium, and
burnium, where performance is growing, the but the
battery life is decreasing, the weight is growing, and
the cost is growing. Well, most of these
are actually not very good processors. Laptium seems reasonable.
It gives you good performance. Five hour battery life is
not too bad, four ounces for the processor you can build
a laptop with that, and about $100 for the processor.
The laptop will probably be about $1,000, so that's fine. Going
with the slowium, it's not too bad. It's going to be
half as fast. But you can still do a lot of
things with it. It gives you excellent battery life. Possibly even
a lighter laptop, and it's going to be cheap. So, these two
are probably reasonable laptop processors. Fastium is a lot
faster. Very little battery life. You'll probably have to keep
it plugged in. It's relatively heavy, so this is
going to be a very heavy laptop. And it's going to be
more expensive, but it's still not an unreasonable laptop.
So clearly, the designs in the middle are actually better
laptop processors than the ones on the extremes. So, we
really have to do, is decide whether the Crawlium or
the Burnium is the worst laptop processor. Here we have
something that is about one tenth of a performance of
a reasonable laptop processor. Extremely good battery life. Probably you
could make this as big as a cell phone, and
very, very cheap. So, this is not such a bad
processor. There are still things you can do with it,
and some people might want a lot of this, of
this kind. In contrast, here we have something that has
four times the performance of the Laptium. The
battery life of all of two minutes. 20 pounds
for the processor including the heat sink and
so on. So, probably this is not really going to
be portable. And it's going to be extremely, extremely
expensive. So, as you can see, the highest performance
processor here is actually the worst laptop processor.
So as you can see, between the crawlium and
the burnium, here we have something that is very slow but also very light and
has a long battery life. Which is
probably better than having something that is significantly
faster with almost no battery life, spinal
injuries from carrying it around and extremely expensive,
so when you drop it, you drop $15,000 worth of laptop. And you will drop it.